We have a voicemail number. That number
is two one nine two. David P. Here is a
voicemail from someone saying, hey, would covid
be taken seriously by the right if it became
flesh eating? It's actually a good question.
Speaker 5: Hey, I'm calling from central New
Jersey. Yeah. I had a thought about people
that are fairly covid. And my thought was,
does the thing you have to maybe mutate to the
point where it makes body parts fall off or
is like a flesh eating virus?
My point is for people to
quit being in denial. Yeah. And it takes
something like that for everybody to all
be on board about how bad this disease is.
Speaker 1: I do think that if covid mutated to
become flesh eating and the death rate went up
to 10 percent, which would be a global tragedy
of historic proportions, by the way, you will
see more people on the right take it seriously,
but not all. No matter how crazy you think we've
seen them be, there will always be some holdouts.
And even if covid became a 10 percent death, flesh
eating disease, you would see the deniers continue
to deny it's an unfortunate problem in the United
States. We'll talk on today's Bonas show about the
simmon Byles Olympic situation. We will talk about
the hundred dollar cash offer for New Yorkers,
New York City residents getting vaccinated.
And we will talk about Florida mayors who are
defying run to Santurce with masks and
vaccine mandates. All of those stories
and more on today's Bonas show. Sign up at
Join Pakman dot com. I'll see you there.